30 років тому Східна Німеччина і Західна Німеччина об'єдналися в одну державу.
Ця подія змінила історію і принесла з собою низку викликів.
Це був унікальний процес. Нічого подібного в історії ще не було.
Першим викликом була сама ідея возз'єднання. Аби зрозуміти чому, треба зазирнути в минуле...
У 1945 рік, коли закінчилася Друга світова війна.
Нацистська Німеччина розшматувала Європу і забрала мільйони життів у Голокості, перш ніж зазнала поразки.
Союзники-переможці - СРСР, Великобританія, Франція і США поділили Німеччину між собою,
аби тримати окремі сектори під контролем.
Розбіжності між СРСР і західними країнами призвели до розділу Німеччини.
У 1949 році на карті світу з'явилися дві країни: капіталістична ФРН на заході та соціалістична НДР на сході.
Після падіння Берлінського муру в 1989 році виникла ідея возз'єднання.
Однак колишні союзники потребували гарантій, що об'єднана Німеччина ніколи знову не стане загрозою.
Радянський Союз був на межі економічного колапсу. Тож ФРН пообіцяла профінансувати виведення радянських військ з НДР.
Європейців і США переконали зобов'язання майбутньої єдиної Німеччини: відмова від розробки зброї масового ураження
- біологічної, хімічної та атомної, обмежена армія, інтегрована в НАТО,
та збереження певного контингенту військ союзників, а також активніша євроінтеграція.
Таким чином виникло відчуття, що буде якась широка і глибока європейська структура,
в яку може бути інтегрована об'єднана Німеччина.
Єдина Німеччина не буде в ній домінувати. Вона буде її частиною, а відтак -  безпечною.
На перших вільних виборах у НДР перемогу здобули партії, які виступали за якнайшвидше возз'єднання.
3 жовтня 1990 року дві Німеччини стали однією країною.
Залагодивши правові питання, взялися за економічне об'єднання.
Інтегрувати соціалізм в капіталізм виявилося нелегкою справою.
У наступні 30 років східні землі отримали понад два трильйони євро дотацій, щоб піднятися на рівень західних.
Західні німці фінансували це податком солідарності на прибуток - понад 5 відсотків. Певною мірою це спрацювало.
Продуктивність зросла. ВВП на душу населення у східних землях в 1990 році становив 43 відсотки від рівня на заході.
Рівень безробіття у Східній Німеччині спочатку різко зріс, однак поступово відрив від західних земель зменшується.
Однак деякі спроби покращити ситуацію мали неочікувані наслідки. Наприклад, валютний союз.
Уряд ухвалив обмін марки НДР на більш сильні дойчмарки за курсом 1:1.
Заощадження на сході раптово збільшили свою вартість. Однак це мало негативний вплив на східнонімецькі компанії.
Їхня продукція подорожчала, водночас не ставши затребуваною.
У перші роки після возз'єднання Німеччини понад 14 000 східнонімецьких підприємств були приватизовані
- багато з них невдовзі закрилися.
Східнонімецькі підприємства, які до того 40 років боролися зі структурними проблемами,
тепер опинилися перед обличчям глобальної конкуренції на світовому ринку.
Ще одним викликом стало об'єднання двох суспільств.
Східне суспільство було соціалістичним соціумом, яке ґрунтувалося на принципах соціальної рівності.
На заході панувало суспільство капіталізму з конкуренцією та ієрархіями.
У новій об'єднаній Німеччині почали брати гору західні цінності. Багато східних німців відчули себе громадянами другого сорту.
Такі настрої зберігаються досі. Опитування 2019 року серед східних німців показало, що 80% респондентів вважають,
що Захід недостатньо визнає їхні досягнення.
Це вказує на те, що возз'єднання Німеччини ще далеко не завершене.
І все ж, єдина Німеччина має репутацію дієздатної, стабільної і демократичної країни.
У цілому, я думаю, возз'єднання пройшло дуже успішно. Принаймні з огляду на те, що нинішня Німеччина
- це миролюбна і демократична країна. Але цей процес ще триває. Це ще не кінець...